[Music]
okay for this one i want you guys to
guess how they were able to accomplish
this
a newly married california couple goes
viral after their entire wedding
ceremony
reportedly only cost them 500 bucks they
did it at court
they didn't over zoom it was a full like
so it's a full ceremony um they stole
everything a full ceremony
a full one like you mean like at a
church how many people did they say it
wasn't in a church it was about about
like 40 to 50 people okay so they bought
500 bucks worth of chipotle yeah about
saying everything else
about a bunch of tacos from del taco
they're like 30 cents yeah for avenue
26. i think they stole
everything they stole it did the whole
enchilada you're committed to the theft
like
photos videos all that stuff photos
videos wedding dress um
cake everyone hostage
oh i like that too that's a good thing
was it on [ __ ] credit card points or
some [ __ ]
[Laughter]
so it was at someone's house they got
their clothes from like goodwill it
definitely wasn't someone's house it was
it was on a it was on a had a mountain
view
is this [ __ ] staking rewards from
luna carter
[ __ ] luna baby did you have an
expensive wedding
no
it was gonna be and then the pandemic
happened oh oh you lucked out huh got
lucky but we all we had a very small oh
a small intimate wedding and it was a
fraction of the cost of the original how
much did you pay
you know like under five thousand
dollars oh that's good oh no way
congratulations yeah and we had deposits
from the other spots that we just used
to this spot because originally it would
have been how much like it was probably
like 20 30 maybe even 40. you know
congratulations and your boy
escaped that bill and it was fire it was
it was actually kind of better too
because you feel bad for not inviting
other people you know and not having
certain people yeah yeah that's what i'm
talking about i actually got an
invitation from you
but i gave you guys an invitation i got
it to the original one before the whole
pandemic thing you know what you know
what's funny recently i didn't realize
that i didn't give out my like the
the second invitational a lot of people
and i
were you in charge of that um no i just
figured like that's what happens with
low budget weddings my dad didn't even
watch our wedding
wow i forgot to send him a link
oh my god
but he's like yeah don't worry about it
yeah you know i gotta watch it damn
actually he goes i know what happens at
those things yeah whatever it's fine you
guys do a dance it's fine it's all good
pretty straightforward yeah it was but
it was really cool it was really
intimate and it was actually
i i i personally liked it it was more
our style i think that's dope could you
see yourself um doing it downsizing
to 40 people
could you see yourself being able to
plan a 500 wedding no [ __ ] way as
soon as they find out it's a wedding and
you do it anywhere
it's already like
premium prices premium prices they [ __ ]
you over
was it in ukraine
[Laughter]
i just saw
a [ __ ] war zone
i'd be like yeah
it would be cheaper it's probably
cheaper than those things
we'll give you a discount on account of
the whole you know yeah
don't say anything
the elephant in the room
and what is it what happened i'll show
you guys a video are any of us close um
who's the closest bart
oh my god
here's here's the video of their wedding
wow oh that picture alone is 500 bucks
that's what i'm saying
isn't that sick for like so yeah 500 is
their whole like thing well
yeah i was about to say this taking on
the new iphone 11 good camera but [ __ ]
that itself is more than 500 bucks that
was good lighting that dress and [ __ ]
suit is already 500 bucks the flowers
get you too i don't get that oh they
they went to angel's crest or something
yes yeah exactly
so they held it at angela's crash on one
of these turn like those little like
turnarounds i don't know you could do
that you could do it if you have less
than 50 people that's genius dude
dude not everyone's going to do this
it's ruined that is absolutely genius
shares were in the budget
one dollar that really is genius how
much is the rental chairs
i don't know but they kept it pretty
probably like 200 bucks so the 500 bucks
was for the gas dude
they just paid for that they filled up
over by barbers dressed like less than
50 bucks or something like that oh she
got it from shane she actually
wait really yeah bro that's [ __ ]
right that's funny i'm so glad you got
that
you can rent the turnout
well they didn't even have to rent it
they just blocked it with all their cars
just pull it up oh i see
that's honestly genius dude what about
all the subaru's like where
you just got to deal with it you know
so they just did a quick ceremony that's
[ __ ] bad they fold up the chairs and
then they had a party right there that's
so good
they had an actual after part like a
reception at a different place oh where
did they go at another turn corner there
they went to the the more i look at it
it is kind of cheap
right yeah it is yeah they they large
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is that
we need the fashion we need the fashion
point of view but actually we know what
it looks like dude because when you're
there a lot of people go and do [ __ ]
donuts in those turtles
so the whole ground is covered in tire
tracks and [ __ ] maybe it would be cool
if they had a sign like a mile down the
road that said hey wedding going on
please do not
race
and then there's cars that are
constantly driving by yeah that
videographer did a great job though
because they like hit all those things
yeah but i like going on [ __ ] dirty
ass nissan the wedding dress is forty
seven dollars
what's she in
sheen
dude sheen is like the worst yeah it's
fashion brand in the world is it like
forever 21 or whatever dude it's
literally
the next worse it's like 10 times worse
than the next worst what's the next
worst fashion nova yes something like
fashion
fashion nova don't even hold a candle
what makes fast fashion bad because the
sheen will put i think it's a ridiculous
output of like a hundred thousand new
styles a month wow yeah and it's just
like all these like pieces are like dirt
you know what i mean like it's just
waste like a lot of it is she in a
product of child labor definitely yeah
it's all the it's all the worst things
combined plus they're probably like
racist plus they're probably like
brothers are probably evil press they're
probably like killing people did you
hear that north korea some of the some
of the high-end clothing that you you
have might come from north korea did you
did you know that
really yeah because they did a deep dive
and then they said that
some of the companies in china
it says it's made in china but what they
do is they'll send materials to north
korea north korea sends it back to china
and then yeah and then they manufacture
they did a [ __ ] deep dive on it it
was like some gene companies some
high-end places and then it went to
europe and i was like damn dude that's
crazy it was made at a north korean
slave camp
holy yeah the [ __ ] and [ __ ] is crazy
though
so i don't know man my bugle boy jeans
they might be north korea
you know i don't know
i know they seem north korean-ish it's
not worried about your bugle boy jeans
it might be comfy not ethically sourced
man yeah the [ __ ] stuff is just scary
because it's just how much
output they have yeah and like how much
is just being wasted like where does it
go
we wear for like a week and then we we
donate it or whatever and it ends up
pretty much in southeast asia or africa
or whatever and also just how much they
don't sell it's just there yeah you know
getting tossed
away like we don't know where it goes to
the abyss
the close abyss man i'm kind of glad
that like our generation too we're not
forced or pressured to like have these
expensive weddings we're like imagine
like everybody like the boomer
generation right
you it was like a weird social stigma
like you spent that you have to spend a
lot of money like it was you have to
invite percentage of your annual income
yeah
and then you have to go through all that
[ __ ] and blow all [ __ ] kinds of money
and i think it's still like that in a
lot of communities but like i feel like
it's way more
accepted now especially during the
pandemic especially for a reception
right i understand like if you have a
big party after your uh
your wedding but like the actual
ceremony like it doesn't need to be that
expensive
because you know it's something like
that for 500 bucks it looks pretty great
it looks pretty classy
the pictures look good yeah the average
cost of a wedding in california what do
you think it is 40 grand that's what i'm
thinking i'll say 30. people go to those
[ __ ] temecula wine countries and [ __ ]
those are so expensive too or that one
farm with the giraffe god 30 grand for a
wedding yeah
yeah it is 33 grand
the average cost of a california wedding
that's a toyota camry sport
fully loaded yeah that doesn't include
that doesn't include the ring either
yeah that's so true getting married
probably cost like 50 grand all right so
were the rings were the rings included
in this 500 dollar budget i i don't
believe the ring was gone bro they ain't
got no freaks
yeah they got they just got those like
fitness bands from where they're good
that's so dope though
[ __ ] eight dollars on amazon
it tracks my steps
buying a house together like down paying
using 33 grand to down pay a house
together that's way more romantic
they could [ __ ] do foreign you know
they're like we'll blow that on that or
whatever i don't like less people
getting married too in general yeah
that's true it's so boring
spoken like a true married man so at
their uh oh you know those shirts to
where it's like it's like the husband in
like with like a ball and chain around
his ankle
game over
that's an ironic tee right that's an
ironic thing i have like two of them
it's just like game over i'm like who's
who's buying
who's making this yeah who's at the
airport like
it's kind of a 50 year old dude it's a
bunch of like married white guys going
true oh this is hilarious the boys got
to see this
and then they wear it to the barbecue
am i right am i right
yeah so in this wedding reception the uh
the guests paid for their own food and
stuff wow they just had it at a lot of
ubereats
they passed the phone around
and put your order in put your order in
i mean that makes sense because you
could just do a deal with a restaurant
or a bar and then just hit hit the uh
hit the tab you know like that's true
that's probably the best way to do it
honestly i get happy for people who save
money on weddings i'm just like dude
good job i love a good deal yeah i love
a good deal yeah it's pretty tight
especially like i mean if dude like most
normal people don't have that kind of
money like who has 30 grand to drop on a
normal even if you are kind of wealthy
like 30 grand a drop on a day is [ __ ]
a lot of people going to debt just to do
that yeah can you write that off if
you're kim kardashian you can write it
off if you're influenced you can write
off your wedding yeah you can you film
it it's advertised no like if you just
record it and post it on social media
that's a write-off yeah
see you missed your chance could it be
no it's all greg
you could have had your wedding be a
nutritionist
you should have did like five push-ups
there should be your wedding in an mma
cage
i'm an idiot dude i don't get taxes bro
[Music]
[Music]
you